come implementing a new rule no smiling
you gotta have anger behind you because
we have a pasta dough blade this week
[Music]
give me the serious faces Hannah you did
smile in the beginning there how could
you not smile when you're dancing
I mean I'm telling you I got so excited
it was like I I tried to turn it into a
growl but well let me ask you this when
you're going growl who are you thinking
about I did the multiple people already
went based on there was multiple guys we
saw you go beast tonight in that package
who are you thinking about when you were
smash and stuff with a baseball bat well
there is multiple bottle multiple it
actually was not enough bottle powerful
stuff okay so you you you improved this
week a lot of compliments from the
judges how did that feel it felt really
great because this dance was so hard
like I mean we put in a lot of hard work
and I think it was a great week for us
to like get on the same pages have to
communicate with each other and we made
a lot of strides moving toward in you
know in the connection and how we speak
and ya know together so you can do like
better like in the ballroom and so it
was great to have the scores and the
compliments that we got from the judge I
think it all came from seeing her in the
rage room I got really scared I think
she is a scary beast you got the
necklace on girl I know no no I know
because I I got this necklace and I
started I wore it the first person he
was like no you're gonna wear that
killed it the first day was like that
was amazing so you've gone sexy you've
gone fun you've gone rayji what's the
plan for Disney Week
I don't know what do you mean what do
you what do you imagine when you see
Disney we could princess be whatever she
wants to see the princess she could have
been the piece I mean wouldn't that be
amazing for him to be beauty and me to
be the B is 2019 whatever okay come on
we'll see what happens we have reason to
believe we are pregnant okay he was like
my dad on the show like whenever I see
him on he's like how you doing today I'm
like thanks for asking
you guys are like kids yeah but it is
such a beautiful it's a miracle and I'm
so happy for them you know and also Leah
Remini also almost Leah Remini almost
got in a fistfight tonight with Len
who's a bigger beast your Lea oh I think
we should be on the same team okay
you don't want to mess with that
[Music]